[Music]
on this sunday night
the covet 19 record in alberta more than
6 000 new cases over three days i find
the numbers
appalling honestly the challenges facing
the jason kenny government
the threat of an ambulance strike in
ontario which is already
under strain from icu cases we welcome
you back to planet earth
plus splashed down from 68 million miles
out of this world and the british
challenge to pay tribute
to sir tom
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in
alberta where there is frustration and
fear after a record-setting weekend for
covin-19 infections
over 6 000 new cases were reported over
the last three days
alberta still leads the country in
active cases per capita
double the number being reported in hard
hit ontario
hospitals have not yet reached their
breaking point yet
but with so many sick it may just be a
matter of time
heather yorks west has our top story
tonight
in alberta the risk of covid19 infection
has
never been higher and yet on a weekend
where the province posted a record
number of new cases hundreds of people
gathered in central alberta for
a rodeo with no masks in sight i do not
think people are evil
i think that they are misguided and that
misguidedness is actually really
damaging to the entire community
honestly
the event comes just days after
alberta's premiere promised to get
tougher on those floating public health
restrictions
alberta health services says it's
considering legal options against the
events organizers the paramedic response
unit paramedic nate pike who was also
running for a seat on calgary's city
council
says he encountered a large gathering
over the weekend too
it was right outside the emergency
medical services headquarters
he says he struggled to control his
anger as he approached the crowd
and i just said look you guys this is
real and when we come home after
12 hours or however long of
trying to fight this thing and we see a
bunch of people having a party on our
front doorstep
it hurts the fact is the stakes in
alberta are higher than ever before
this week alberta health services met
with staff to discuss its cova 19
triage protocol a guide for which
patients would receive
care in the event hospitals become
overwhelmed
it's something dr noel gibney believes
could happen in as little as
three weeks time looking at modeling
that the date has been remarkably
accurate we could hit that threshold
anywhere from may 22nd
onwards still alberta's current level of
restrictions are
less than what was in effect during the
height of the province's previous two
waves
patios remain open malls churches and
hair salons too
what is closing is the alberta
legislature the province canceling its
spring sitting for at least
two weeks to prevent the government says
covenant teens
further spread heather urex west global
news
calgary in ontario some medical experts
warn the province is nearing the kova 19
triage protocol stage where
they'll be forced to choose which
patients live and which die
catherine ward has more on the icu
situation in the hardest hit regions of
ontario
emergency departments and icu's key
battlegrounds in the fight against
covid19
our icus were still full from the second
wave when we started receiving more
patients from the third weight
hospital capacity and staffing are where
success and failure are in a constant
state of flux
in ontario's york region north of
toronto dr steve flindle sees this play
out daily
in the er i remember a day when we said
350
icu patients would mean hospitals can
function properly
we're more than double that now and the
ramifications
from that are going to last months if
not years
critical care services ontario reports
another 51
icu admissions saturday there are now
more than 2 000 patients in critical
care across the province
886 are there because of covet 19.
in peel region dr andrew healey says
triage protocols
have not been required and hospitals
have the ability to care for
anyone needing help but he says
continued vigilance
is needed if we take our eye off the
ball
we are certainly at risk of getting to
the point where our numbers would exceed
our ability to care for people
on top of all this union members with
orange paramedics have voted 94 percent
in favor of a strike
if necessary the workers have been key
in helping transfer critically ill
coveted patients to
icu's across the province the union for
the emergency helicopter and ambulance
service wants the four government to
exempt them from bill
124 legislation which forces a one
percent wage increase cap
and also limits bargaining rights
they're the only paramedics across the
entire province
that are captured by this legislation so
as the premier he has the right
to waive the legislation in this
circumstance
over in scarborough dr lisa solomon says
she worries about how much more the
system can handle
really we don't have much more capacity
left
and people really need to understand
that we're
getting very close to maximizing our
capacity catherine ward global news
toronto the u.s is seeing a similar
trend as canada in the demographic
ending up in hospital with kova 19.
35 percent of new admissions are now
people in their 20s 30s
and 40s but younger people are shying
away from getting their vaccines
and as jennifer johnson reports the
vaccine supply
is beginning to outpace demand
after racing to vaccinate older and
elderly americans a population hit hard
in earlier waves of the pandemic
doctors are now seeing a clear
demographic shift in new covet 19 cases
young adults are filling up hospital
wards young people have this
misconception
that covett is no big deal it is a big
deal
and we've seen a lot of young people now
hospitalized young people with long-term
infections
that go on for months and months and
months states have opened up vaccination
sites to everyone over the age of 16.
following an unprecedented rollout
vaccination rates are now dropping by
about 500
000 a day nationwide doctors are telling
young people the vaccines are their best
weapon against the virus
but they're hearing a different story on
the internet in social media there are a
lot of rumors going around about how the
vaccine is not important or how we don't
need it because we're not at high risk
many young adults are also being told
the shots will make them sicker than
covet 19 will
which medical experts dispute people are
saying that like
oh they feel like sick for a long time
that it's not worth it
young adults 18 to 30 make up the
highest number of unvaccinated people in
the country
some states like west virginia are using
incentives offering a 100
savings bond to anyone 16 to 35 who gets
vaccinated
our kids today
don't really probably realize
just how important they are in shutting
this thing down
some young adults don't need convincing
anxious to get back to life as they once
knew it
if everyone gets their vaccinations then
hopefully we can go back to school
normally without masks
you can hug your friends if you want sit
at lunch tables
together many colleges are now taking a
hard line
requiring students be vaccinated before
returning in the fall
so that this school year isn't a repeat
of last year's
jennifer johnson global news washington
india has recorded its deadliest day of
the kova 19 pandemic
in the last 24 hours more than 3 600
people died
it's the fourth straight day india has
experienced over three thousand deaths
ottawa has sent 10 million dollars to
the indian red cross and as michael
couture explains
it's now looking for other ways to help
and a warning
some viewers may find images in this
story disturbing
all this woman wanted was to bring her
dead husband home
but with no ambulances in sight she was
forced to call a rickshaw
instead this is how bad it is in india
the south asian country has recorded 250
000 confirmed covid19 related deaths
since the start of the pandemic the
actual death toll
is likely much higher indo-canadians are
left feeling helpless
as they hear horrifying stories from
family
i talked to my cousin this week and she
had told me when she was waiting to get
her vaccine at her local hospital
there was one body being transported
every minute pastor who died from covet
medical oxygen remains a precious
commodity in the country
even as shipments start to flow in by
train
help is slowly trickling into india from
the international community
germany's shipment of 100 ventilators
landed in new delhi overnight
uzbekistan and france also sent medical
equipment
each of these units can provide oxygen
during more than 12 years to a 250 bed
hospital in india
canada's contribution so far has been
cash 10 million dollars directly to the
indian red cross for immediate needs and
talks continue
about sending equipment like ventilators
the public health agency of canada
is you know reviewing what we have in
our national stockpile
and first and foremost making sure that
you know what
we can send is not something that's
needed here in canada
now some in canada's south asian
community are even suggesting
gifting the remaining 1.5 million
vaccine doses
we were supposed to get from the serum
institute of india
back to the country considered the
world's pharmacy
while india has halted all vaccine
exports
minister gould says it could be part of
the conversation
when doses begin flowing again we want
to make sure that canadians get their
second dose of the astrazeneca vaccine
you know whether that comes from the
serum institute or whether it comes from
another area we continue to work on that
understanding that the global pandemic
won't be over
until it's over in every country across
the world
michael couter global news
some countries are beginning to get out
of this pandemic because of an effective
rollout of vaccines
the distribution of vaccines began last
december in under five months
israel has managed to get at least one
job into 62 percent of its population
for the uk it's 51 canada is now just
over
33 even in the throes of a lockdown
there are signs in this country
that vaccines could turn the tide in the
weeks ahead
eric sorensen reports as long lines
snake towards vaccination sites and
canadians
masked and desperate for shots wait
hours for pop-up clinics
it's hard to imagine when normal will
return
but it is happening elsewhere the masks
came off in
israel this month and nightlife has
returned in the uk
honestly it feels so good it just feels
like we're out of prison
what the uk and israel have in common is
a high percentage of vaccinations
there's no question that we're starting
to get the pandemic really well under
control at the moment canada is just
beginning to catch up
after a slow start this country has
overtaken most g20 nations in
administering vaccines per capita
and led by pfizer canada will double its
weekly total to more than 2 million
doses a week
starting this month so when will it make
a difference
as you get more people immunized it
makes the disease
less transmissible to others so you know
as you get past 50 60
you see it you know happening in terms
of less cases
with an accelerated vaccine pace coming
half the population in canada could get
a first dose by late may
public health officials see 75 percent
as a threshold when a semblance of
ordinary life could return
the types of restrictions i think that
could be looked at obviously would be a
maybe encouraging more sort of outdoor
gatherings in terms of
maybe a people being able to to get
together it will depend on other factors
covid variant hot spots are less likely
to open as early as other areas
and getting to 75 percent depends on
canadians continuing to march in for
their shots
which they are doing an ipsos survey in
november found barely half
52 percent of canadians would take a
vaccine as soon as they could without
hesitation
a february survey saw the number rise to
66 percent
and in april ipsos found 75 percent
would take a vaccine as soon as possible
no hesitation vaccine enthusiasm is
important
more people are getting talking about it
you know there's more opportunities to
get vaccinated
with people enthusiastic to take the
vaccines that's only going to help
with vaccines coming in bigger numbers
and a high willingness to get a jab
canada could be among the few countries
that can lift restrictions
and be well protected by sometime this
summer
eric sorensen global news toronto
coming up afghanistan on high alert as
american troops begin pulling out
police dash cam footage captured a
heart-stopping collision in australia
a large truck was slowing down on a
highway because of poor visibility from
a fire nearby
that's when another truck hit it from
behind the officer who was watching this
all happened managed to get out of the
way
luckily no one was seriously hurt
in afghanistan's capital a fire rolled
through several gasoline tanker trucks
killing at least seven people
and injuring 14 others the cause of the
incident is under investigation but
officials have ruled out a terrorist
incident still afghanistan is on high
alert because of threats from the
taliban
and the u.s has begun withdrawing troops
with a final deadline
set for september 11th israel is
observing a national day of mourning to
remember the 45 people
including two canadians killed in a
stampede
[Music]
hundreds sang and prayed during a
spontaneous memorial
last night in jerusalem 45 people
including two quebecers were killed on
friday in a stampede
at an annual religious festival tens of
thousands of people
attended the event
still ahead helping the men behind
domestic violence
the commander of canada's special forces
unit has been placed on indefinite leave
following revelations he wrote a letter
in support of a soldier found guilty of
sexual assault
four years ago major general peter dawg
wrote a character reference
for a soldier convicted of sexually
assaulting a comrade's wife
a statement from the acting chief of the
defense staff says
we must keep learning and ensure such
situations are not repeated going
forward
in doing so we must always have the
victim's perspective at the forefront
and be accountable for our actions the
move comes as retired supreme court
justice luis arbour begins a review of
the military's approach
to sexual misconduct in this country one
woman or girl is killed
every two and a half days that's the
finding of a report by the canadian
femicide observatory for
justice and accountability in quebec the
government is calling it a crisis
after 10 femicides in less than five
months
now the province is planning to spend
233 million dollars
to stop violence against women and
nearly 10 percent of that will go to
organizations
to help the men committing this violence
as amanda jeliwicki reports
experts say men need more resources to
change their behavior
it's a staggering number since january
10 quebec women have been killed because
of suspected domestic violence
please ask for help the help is there
calling the situation a crisis
the quebec government is spending
millions to help this time
investing in programs that support
violent men
we have to address the source of the
problem which is
being able to help men violent men who
who ask for help genvieve gebo says the
emergency 20 million dollars will go to
34 male support groups across the
province
it is an additional 30 percent of money
that is given to the organizations
to make sure that they are able to hire
more people
experts say men are often overlooked
when it comes to domestic violence
about ten thousand men ask for help each
year
but few resources exist if they're not
serviced right away their anxiety grows
they can become a little more hopeless
even angrier darylton james helps
counsel violent men
he says traditionally they are just
thrown in jail and not offered help
he believes that needs to change men
do require services not just punishment
or consequences
simply going to jail does not help them
reintegrate back into their families
groups who support women welcome the
investment but they say more
collaboration is needed to truly tackle
the problem
can we work together can we sit down
together
because they need our expertise to
provide
an adequate safety net to the woman as
long as the government will work
in silos it won't be
strong enough men currently wait about
two months before accessing group help
the government hopes its investment will
cut that number in half
amanda delawicki global news montreal
up next from climbing walls to eating
mall teasers
how brits are paying tribute to the
captain
and on behalf of nasa and the spacex
teams we welcome you back to planet
earth and thanks for flying spacex
mission control also joked that the
astronauts earned 68 million miles for
the frequent flyer program
the four returned to earth in the first
nighttime splashdown of a nasa crew
since 1968.
they came home in the same capsule
resilience
that they left on five months ago
it's been three months since the loss of
captain sir tom moore from covet 19.
the british war veteran raised millions
to fight the virus
with his 100th birthday challenge he
would have turned 101 on friday
so this weekend people across the uk are
doing their own challenge in honor of
sir tom
here's crystal grandson
on what would have been captain sir tom
moore's 101st
birthday his family kicked off a new
chapter
building on his legacy we want people to
pick up that number 100 join us in the
challenge
do anything you can and raise money for
charity the captains are foundational
any charity of your choice
moore gained worldwide recognition last
year
he walked 100 laps of his garden and
with every step
raised millions for the uk's national
health service
you know we still feel his loss it's
just a few months
since he died but this is so powerful
because here we are in his legacy the
lasting legacy of hope he gave to us and
to everybody
hope it turns out is still in great
demand
but there is a large and dedicated team
ready to step into more shoes
[Music]
the challenges are all different but the
goal is the same
complete a task 100 times in support of
a charity
hi i'm harmony and i'm going to be
climbing this wall 100 pounds
for captain tom it's difficult for hans
but she does like to push herself don't
you
yeah we heard about the captain tom 100
challenge
we had to do it we just had to do it
because
we captain tom has the same hopes they
have the same beliefs
as us the belief that everyone can make
a difference harmony rose allen is
raising money to build an accessible
playground
at her school
many of the challenges are truly
inspiring
others well they're more delicious i'm
going to eat
more jesus my fave
here we are
99 to go celebs are definitely adding
flavor
and flair what he's brought us of course
with the captain tom 100 that we've
talked about before is
is this incredible ability to cross the
boundaries of gender
race social status nationality and age
no boundaries
just hope through action 99
crystal commansing global news
london
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is the kennebecas river in new
brunswick
thanks for watching good night
you